yeah yeah I'm a professional when I got  the call to do Sonic it was really  exciting  good morning my rural Chum mr. dr.  Robotnik he is a madman I can't with  that guy you're mine the Hedgehog that  was an illegal left by the way of course  he's a 300 IQ so it took me a week and a  half to prepare Robotnik wants to  control humanity with his machines Sonic  is a power that he needs to control the  world no but thank you for asking  oh that's not good  I just thought you might like a latte  with steamed Austrian goat milk of  course I would a lot of take I love the  way you make them I think I'm kind of  writing the zeitgeist with this  character the mustache was ridiculous I  wish I could grow it being able to do a  movie that brings a good memory back and  connects with new generations of people  it is really amazing I've been very  lucky in that regard my blood every  night I'm just having so much fun we've  created a monster we won't be able to  control  you